Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Our
finaling, our final, our final
examination
or meditation
on this narration
of
which was collected by im Muslim
at the conclusion of which our prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
explains to Omar explains to the
companions.
He says
that this man who came to ask me those
questions on that day.
It was
who came to you all to teach you all
your religion.
Notice here who he ascribed the teaching
to.
He said that Gibl
is the one who came to teach them.
But all he did was ask questions.
Correct?
Then how is it that Gabriel
is the one who is considered to have
taught them when all he did was ask
questions?
The answer is those questions
were the cause
behind that teaching occurring. Correct?
And in Islam,
in the judgment of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala,
the cause for something,
the cause for an action
has the ruling of the one who does the
action.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said,
He says subhanahu waala indeed we write
what they have put forth for themselves
of acts and their impacts their effects
the effects of their actions is also
considered to be part of our actions.
For this reason,
this this works here, the pendulum here
swings on both sides. This is for good
things. It can also be for bad things.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam.
He said,
"Oh,
the one who leads another to something
is the one who does that thing."
Therefore,
in a narration in Bkari Muslim, the
prophet sallall.aii
said,
he said, "One of the greatest of the
greatest of sins,
one of the most major of major sins
is that a man insult his own parents."
In our time, unfortunately, that's not
very peculiar. We don't need any more
questions. We don't need to ask how
something could happen.
But at that time, in the time of the
companions, in the time of human
decency,
the companions were perplexed by this.
Who would insult his own parents? How
does that even happen?
They asked. And the prophet sallall.aii
[Silence]
He said a man would insult another man's
father and in retaliation the insulted
would turn and insult his.
Who is responsible for this? The person
didn't insult his own father directly
but he was the cause for what? For his
father to be insulted.
Therefore he is considered to have
insulted his own parent.
He has insulted his own parent.
And so this is the point here is that
Gabriel when he came and he asked those
questions he was actually given the
reward of the one teaching. Does it mean
that this excludes the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam? Of course
not. He provided the answers and he
taught. However, Gibl is considered to
be a teacher in that in that exchange as
well.
So this narration
has so many important points to the
point that it's been referred to as
sunnah. This narration has been referred
to as the reference and the mother of
all other narrations and the sunnah of
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
just like
is
so we haven't even really scratched the
surface when with regards to the
meanings embedded in this narration.
However, before we move on to the next
narration, we'd to take a bit of a
review of this narration, inshallah, to
make sure that we have
understood the most critical elements
and points of it.
Says that as they were sitting in the
masid with the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam. A man walked in with
very black hair, very white clothing. No
one recognized him to be a local, nor
did he have the appearance of a
traveler.
And this man came in in this form for
what reason? We later find out this was
Giblam.
Why did he come in this form?
[Arabic recitation]
And Gabriel
came in and he sat very close to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam and he
aligned his knees to the knee to his
knees and he placed his hands on his
thighs and he said, "Yeah,
tell me and define for me what is Islam?
Islam in the Arabic language means what?
What is the meaning?
Huh?
[Silence]
Right.
Islam.
My Jews
[Silence]
for
Islam. Islam in the Arabic language is
to submit. To submit to become subi
subi submissive which is
what is the legislative meaning of
Islam?
These are the elements. These are the
pillars of Islam. We want the actual
definition of al Islam. Now this is why
we're reviewing because these things are
so critical when we say for instance
what is the definition of Islam? What
this means is
this is the bare minimum threshold for a
person to be considered a Muslim. If a
person does not have this description,
they are not Muslim. Right? So we're not
asking about the pillars of Islam. The
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was
asked
tell me about the
about Islam meaning it's its its
rights its most prominent rights.
However, we want the definition of Islam
which is the bare minimum of what makes
a person Muslim as opposed to what
excludes a person from being Muslim. We
gave this definition. We said three
things. Yes.
-huh.
Well, you're you're creeping up on it a
little bit, but not close enough. You're
you're you're you're getting around the
well, but you got to you got to draw the
water. Now, Islam, memorize these
things. These are not this knowledge
that is being shared that I sit on this
chair and share with you. This is not
optional knowledge about your religion.
These are the critical components of
your religion that no Muslim has any
excuse to be ignorant of especially in
the quote unquote age of information.
Right? Islam
has three elements. What is Islam?
Islam is the following definition.
[Silence]
I'll repeat it again.
Islam
is defined as
it is submission to Allah with
monotheism.
And it is submission to him with
obedience.
Okay.
And disassociation
from shik and its people.
What is what is Islam?
Islam.
Islam is
submission to Allah with monotheism.
Meaning that we worship only Allah alone
without any partners. Somebody claims to
be a Muslim but worships other than
Allah along with Allah. Can this person
be a Muslim? What about if they pray
five five times a day and sayahillahool
and establish prayer and give zak fast
Ramadan and make
correct? Can they be a Muslim if they
worship other than Allah along with
Allah even if they do all these things?
What about if they memorize the whole
Quran? What about if they go and are
martyed on the battlefield but they
worship other than Allah along with
Allah? Can they be a Muslim? The answer
is no. A person may say well all these
good things and that's the sha right
that's what gives people pause doubt
they say all these good things
are invalidated by this one thing this
isn't mathematics
it's not an issue of two is more than
one not all acts are the same
there are actions which are great and
then there are actions which make a
person and define a person.
And so if a person were to accept Islam
yet they continue to worship other than
Allah, this person cannot be a Muslim.
This is not Islam. Right? So the first
element of Islam,
what is Islam? It is submission to Allah
with monotheism.
Mono meaning onetheism. It's Latin. I
don't really using these
definitions in English. They carry other
connotations but for our intents and
purposes. The second
and it is adherence to Allah with
obedience.
adherence to Allah with obedience.
This means that a person does this mean
that a person has to obey in every
single thing that if they don't obey in
every single thing 100% and they make a
mistake or they stumble or they fall
short that they're somehow Islam is
invalid. No. But what's meant is that
there is a general attitude of holistic
adherence, obedience to Allah. A person,
imagine with me for a second, a people
became Muslim in the prophet's time,
sallallahu alaihi wasallam, and they
said, "Listen, we will
not worship other than Allah. However,
we're not going to pray. We're not going
to fast. We're not going to give zaka.
We're not going to make Hajj. We're not
going to stop eating pork. We're not
going to stop drinking alcohol. We're
going to continue to gamble. We're going
to continue to commit adultery. We're
going to murder. We're going to fight
you. We're going to fight against your
companions. But
would he say that? Well, that's what's
expected of you. Is that what he would
say? Of course not. There has to be a
general holistic attitude of adherence.
Allah is my creator. Muhammad is my
messenger. I must obey. His words are
binding upon me. I have to change
myself. I am not I am not acceptable as
I currently am. There has to be that
general
air of adherence,
right? There is no such thing as a
person becoming Muslim
without changing anything in their life
at all. Nothing. nothing at all. This
person cannot be a Muslim. This is not
Islam
because Islam has three components. The
first is monotheism. The second is what?
There has to be obedience.
And what is the third?
[Silence]
And the third component is
disassociation
from shik and its people
and its people. So what does this mean?
We live in America. Most the people
around us are mushri. Does this mean
that we can't have neighbors that are
mushri? We can't have co-workers that
are mushri. We can't No, of course not.
That's not what is intended.
Disassociation here
is a religious disassociation.
Just you religiously affiliate
yourself with Islam and the Muslim,
you religiously
disassociate yourself from Shik and its
people. Right?
These three elements
that is the definition of Islam
right? This is something that we have to
memorize. When you read the Quran Allah
says those the Muslim will enter
paradise. Who are the Muslim? They are
those who
they they have monotheism.
They have obedience and they are
disassociate themselves from Shik and
its people in all times. The Muslim in
the time of the Muslim in the time of
the Muslim this is Islam
Islam
Islam.
[Silence]
So when Allah says in the Quran and
we'll finish with this he says indeed
the religion the valid acceptable
religion with Allah is what? Islam.
We could exchange that for its
definition. What does the verse mean?
The verse literally says
that indeed the religion, the acceptable
religion with Allah is
submission to Allah withhed monotheism
and
and obedience to him. adherence to
him with holistic obedience and
disassociation from Shik and his people
from polytheism and his people. All
right, let's see if we can't get that
definition one more time before I I
leave you and we'll continue to mention
this. How many times have I mentioned
this sitting in this chair in the past
six months that I've been here? Almost
six months. I say I've probably said it
maybe 50 times. No less than 50.
Probably around more a hundred
times. I said it till I'm blue in the
face. I'll probably keep saying it until
I'm yellow and green and red in the
face. And this is what knowledge is,
right? I once had one of my mash in
the science of hadith. He said something
really that stuck with me years ago. He
said,
"A teacher
who is bored with repetition
is a failure.
And a student who is bored with
repetition is a failure."
Meaning as a student, as a teacher, a
teacher who teaches must
have the longevity of repetition.
Always, always, always, always. You look
at the Quran, what is it repeated?
itself over and over and over in many
different ways. That's what teaching is.
So the first element of Islam is
raise your voice.
It is submission to Allah with
monotheism.
and adherence to Allah with holistic
obedience. And the third
and
disassociation
from
polytheism. Poly meaning more than one,
multiple theism,
polytheism and its people. Memorize
these things. Write them down. It's all
on the camera. You can go back and watch
this again on Facebook, right? And you
take your notes and you review those
notes until you memorize them. And that
way
some guy on the TV or someone on Tik Tok
can't pull the wool over your eyes and
trick you and swindle you out of your
[Arabic recitation]
No, that's that's not true. But we can
say this
there is a difference between
definitions
and judgment,
right? for instance, if we say this
particular thing here
is shik, an act of shik, right? This
particular thing is an act of shik.
Does it mean that every person who does
this thing irrespective of who they are,
where they come from, their level of
education indiscriminately is a
Would
that be correct? No, of course not.
Second of all, numbers
are not what make give us definitions.
Can't say, well, the overwhelming amount
of people that are doing this thing
here,
there's a huge amount of people that do
this thing. Therefore, this could not be
haram. Impossible. That's not how
definitions work. Definitions are taken
from the Quran and Sunnah and applied to
people. Whoever fits the definition fits
it. Whoever does not does not. But when
you say 80% that is a huge percentage.
Why would why would you say that?
[Arabic recitation]
their own religion because of the
Muslims who are always where the tree is
where the Christmas tree is.
[Arabic recitation]
stay with me here. Those 80% or 90% or
100%. the Muslims that you meet, let's
say in Liban here in Tucson, wherever it
is, if you were to stop them and say,
"Do you
if you were to let's let's frame the
question in a different way. Let's say
you and I walked into
a casino." Yeah. Go ahead. Walked into a
casino or walked into a bar or wherever
and found Muslim in there gambling,
drinking, whatever it is. Musliming. We
pulled them aside. We said, "Is this
behavior acceptable?" What would they
say? They say, "No, they fit the second
condition." That's what the second
condition means.
It doesn't mean that they adhere to
everything. that none of us would fit
that condition.